I think yeah so the problem is is that  there's zero advantage to marriage in  the western world for a man there are  zero statistical Advantage if you use  your mind if you use your head instead  of your heart and you look at the  advantages of getting married there are  absolutely not really none because this  new idea of new age feminism just  basically destroys all men and the idea  in the event of her leaving and and it's  very common that women leave right let's  let's stop the a man versus woman attack  et cetera et cetera life's difficult for  everybody we all have different  challenges different things to go  through but if a woman marries a man and  it goes wrong she has emotional  heartbreak fine but if a man marries a  woman it goes wrong he has emotional  heartbreak plus everything he has ever  worked for is ripped out from underneath  him and he has to give that chick money  forever